just went to the Balenciaga show makeup
braid it kind of feels good
2016 Kim Kardashian was robbed at
gunpoint at Paris Fashion Week
makeup free
I wouldn't be awesome if they can go
plastic surgery for you as well yeah
just remove the top look I'm all natural
on the skin but underneath my girl
now that you've got some of that
permanent makeup it's not just the
makeup it's a
permanent makeup about some of the
surgery
you know what because there's permanent
makeup oh there is yeah that's what I'm
saying there is permanent makeup there
is such a thing as permanent makeup yeah
they do like they're going to enhance
like that look the eyebrows the Contour
the lips the the lips the Contour of the
eyes yeah yeah and then after that
there's a Botox shots okay and the lip
injection and the fillers if you guys
don't know preach a second job he
basically judges people who have plastic
surgery yes
[Music]
the robber stole seven million pounds
worth of jewels including Kim's 3.5
million pound engagement ring Believe It
or Not The Heist was committed by a
group of men aged 60 to 72. the Press
dubbed them the grandpa robbers
I'm in Paris to meet one of them
so how did you prepare for the crime I
just went on Instagram she docked her
own self I saw where she was what she
had what she wears
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
um
[Music]
City
his family and are these girls sharing
too much like people now are wondering
if that's to blame and how these guys
knew that she was in their apartment
probably alone
so what happened on the night
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Laughter]
if I was in an emergency situation
there's no way I would know what the
emergency number is in a different
country so my first instinct would be
9-1-1 and I'm crazy then I'm crazy so
you know the emergency number of every
country when I get there okay that's
right especially if I go out 9-1-1 is
the thing because we put it in in USA
movies and put me movies from the states
and it's everywhere in the world but
it's it's not a it's not maybe it's just
it's not that I assume I wouldn't assume
that it is that that would just be the
only number I'd have I wouldn't memorize
whatever emergency number is what I'm
when I'm taking a one week vacation and
I'm going to France or Portugal I'm not
thinking like all right well what's my
emergency numbers
you do you memorize those yeah PTSD
probably I don't know well maybe you
guys feel different let us know in the
comments do you guys memorize the
emergency numbers I doubt y'all do
that
because
are these Kim Kardashian's robbers it's
the first video showing the alleged
thieves on bikes old man hot [ __ ]
bicycles pulled off a seven million
dollar Heist that's crazy Fast Fire
that's crazy that's like that that's a
movie that's a movie that's the movie I
want to see and on foot heading toward
the boutique hotel in Paris
one guy I'm gonna get a bike you get
your bus pass yeah I'm gonna just walk
at that age you got to get your cardio
in did I walk today let me walk after
this Heist shot us to them I'm walking
maybe that's even more box it looks less
suspicious yeah walking away from a
seven million dollar Heist how did you
get caught uh
[Music]
did you know how big of a star she was
hello
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
like in your neighborhood that's
different
suggest Bezos gets robbed for 100
million you think I'm crying over him
I'm not no the Community Center gets
robbed in Smash I feel some different
types how do you feel about the incident
now do you feel guilty at all about what
happened
[Music]
more fish
so do you not think that she was
traumatized
he grabbed me and pulled me towards him
but I wasn't wearing anything underneath
so I was like okay this is like the time
I'm Gonna Get You know like just prepare
yourself
so I did what would your advice be to
celebrities and influencers who are
thinking of posting their belongings on
Instagram
you're not alive you know recently there
was uh some dude who got robbed and
murdered I think at orascos right and
dude was walking around with his chains
and all this other stuff people
speculate on how it happened maybe it
was just I think our opportunity can't
say for sure what I do know is you walk
around with a hundred thousand dollars
on your neck some of them might just
think I could work for three four years
and get taxed on this so I probably got
to work five years to make that kind of
money or I could just snatch it from
your neck and it's tax free now I'm not
saying it's okay I'm not saying it's
good what I'm trying to say is
you learned this early on the more
attention you attract the more problems
you attract the more people know you got
money the more that you're going to draw
the wrong type of ice
that's that's life okay so when I see
this stuff and people getting robbed
influencers being a Kim or somebody
smaller I just think to myself
absolutely what happened to you is not
right but you flaunting your wealth
especially in times where people are
extremely dire and in need I'm not going
to be surprised if you get robbed
the crime itself must have been
absolutely traumatic for her and no one
deserves to be put in that situation
this is one of the first high profile
cases of an influencer being targeted
and it seems to have spurred on a lot of
CopyCat crimes since and social media
was fundamentally the weapon that helped
to pull this off they're not copycare
crafts people have been using people's
social media to Rob them all the minute
social media happen the moment you
Repose at what you had folks were living
with Envy they were going to come for
you that that's something I knew even in
my teenage years I remember going to
House parties on you know through
Facebook events okay and I knew folks
who would go to specific spots because
they knew the people that had money
because they would see it in their
pictures yes and so the house party
would happen they'd get invited in and
these dudes would empty out their shoes
they would empty out their parents
closets like that was things that would
happen even when I was a teenager that's
not a new thing it's always been known
that's why even my parents would tell me
like listen when you go out don't drive
this color card my mom would say red
cars don't tracks police okay uh she
would say don't be loud in public tracks
the wrong kind of attention if you're
going out don't wear any expensive
jewelry my mom knew this when she was
going out in the 80s and the 70s so so
that's not a new thing it's always been
like that's all how do you think the
only people who do this are one people
who don't care about the risk are two
people who are oblivious to the rest but
you can get got and the more you flaunt
in it and you benefited from it but you
draw the wrong eyes if someone like you
nurse a man who's almost 70 years old
can figure out how to rob one of the
most famous people in the world Kim
Kardashian by using SnapChat I don't
think any of us have any hope you're
being hella dramatic my girl I don't
think any of us hurt I don't think any
of us have any hope yes we do stop
posting [ __ ]
that's a [ __ ] dramatic
that's a vision but we don't have any
hope you don't have to post anything you
can just it doesn't have to invest in
your security
you wanna you wanna you wanna play the
game that's fine if you walking around
with a ring on your finger and that [ __ ]
worth 7 million
someone knows if they just snatch it
from you they got retirement for they
and their kids
there's a reason you lock your front
door
you shouldn't be robbed but you'll lock
your front door why cause you understand
[ __ ] might happen and people find out
your door is just open
people rob you when your door is locked
yeah
despite their age the grandpa robbers
set a trend and inspired criminals
around the world to turn to social media
for opportunities
back in the UK I'm meeting a criminal
who tracks his Targets on Instagram and
robs them using a taser
hiya are you okay so you started with
robbing shops did that change when
social media came about
[Music]
this
[Music]
he's a lizard why would I rob somebody
on the street they might have nothing on
them
I mean Target all that risk so let me
just go for these influencers who are
posting where they're at what manager
they got so I know it's always going to
be profitable
that's true
fast facts why would I go on the street
rival ROM dude come out with a charge
for nothing for actually nothing for
peanuts it's just because I try to Rob
someone I didn't have [ __ ] that's crazy
yes
whilst eleanora was watching the rain I
spoke to some other influencers at the
event to see if the news of the acrobat
thieves has changed how they behave
online maybe our brand say I would like
to send you a gift can you please give
me your address and if I won the gift or
if I want you to do a collaboration need
to trust that this is a collaboration
and not somebody that just want to know
where I live sometimes we go to the
unboxing stuff my friends told me Ari
the latest because you can clearly read
where you live that's not safe anybody
can see your stories you have to take a
little attention I guess there's a lot
of people that say maybe that the
influencers almost deserve it because
they've been flaunting their wealth or
not in how much do you agree with that
you know it's your business you know if
it's your business to sure you are an
expensive hotel if it's your business to
show you you buy expensive clothes how
how the hell can you stop doing it if
you're making money for me you know yeah
but you're going to stop making
these chops these jobs come with
inherent risks
you know it's like you become a police
officer like it become an NFL player you
might get a concussion you might get you
might you might you have to understand
these risks if your job is to flaunt
drooling walk around Hey listen I'm glad
it comes with some easy money but
there's a risk involved
there's a risk involved when I did this
online stuff I understand there's a risk
involved depending on how I do it
certain amount of people are going to
start coming after me they're gonna send
me weird messages they're going to try
to put some things on my name
that comes with the territory I'm not
saying it's okay I'm not saying it's
good I'm just saying it is what it is
and maybe I'm
I'm nihilistic a little bit
my whole life
you just kind of have to accept that
there's certain downsides that exist in
the world so the solution to that was
always told to me to be like all right
well how do you adapt that's what I know
adaptability if I know this place is
dangerous or this neighborhood's
dangerous I can either move out or I can
learn to navigate the danger but trying
to remove and change the danger is
possible but it's very complex I'm just
trying to get from point A to point B so
I can pay my bills and take care of my
family you get me I don't have the time
to change the whole world so I get what
you're trying to say but
that's tough
I can only I can only manage what I can
manage yup and I cannot manage other
people's behavior I can only
I can only do me
I can only do me like
so you try to control everybody nah you
can't control everybody and change your
mentality nah there's poor people out
there that need to eat
and that that's that's what's gonna
what's gonna happen yep the influences
are clearly aware of the potential
dangers of posting online but what can
they do for most of them it's their main
source of income is
[Music]
what advice would you give to other
influencers having been through it
yourself yeah
it was quite harrowing to hear
eleanora's Story I mean I don't believe
that any influencer or anyone should
have the whole flat ransacked with all
of their belongings in it she did say
that she had learned from it though I am
kind of interested to see if she hasn't
posted anything because I saw her
filming a lot throughout the night let's
have a little look
she posted two hours ago 58 minutes ago
48 minutes ago there's a lot of stuff
that was at the party showing where she
is
don't post so much hi guys no she said I
don't post anything while I'm at the
event she goes to check her Instagram
with shout out to Vice good job and she
exactly exactly what she said she
wouldn't do her own safety and that's
when you start to say
mental health where the addiction side
of this thing where people are so much
into their social media they're putting
their lives hours it's not like this
girl doesn't know she's already been
robbed you know she's already been
attacked she comes out and says I'm
changing my way she can't change it even
though it's against her own safety and
she's been experiencing it you know how
we know
wow she verbalized it she just [ __ ]
said it you know that that came out
I came out of her mouth she said hey
don't do this don't do that don't do
that if you want to know how dumb this
is it's like imagine Robert your home
gets robbed you left your front door
unlocked okay the next day you leave
your front door locked and the day after
you leave your front door unlocked as
your neighbor I'm gonna look at you like
[ __ ] you just asking to get robbed
lock your front door
you won't do it okay but when it happens
the next time you ain't getting my
sympathy
you ain't got my sympathy oh uh because
I know your door is not unlocked now and
every day after you got robbed my
sympathy for the first time left you get
the next time the first time that
sympathy left okay that's crazy I said
bye-bye and went out the door you know
how I went out the door the door was
unlocked
I
guess old habits die hard eleanora was
extremely lucky that she wasn't in the
flat when the thieves targeted
but it isn't just glamorous girls like
eleanora anyone with a decent following
and a habit for flashing their caches at
risk KES the guru isn't your typical
influencer he's involved in the murky
world of Forex Trading kez uses
Instagram to promote his success but
this attracted the wrong kind of
attention
[Music]
in his house he has everything from
machetes to guard dogs and even a toy
sword you've got a sword up there so I
got the knife there oh okay dog or the
alarm system the [ __ ] is knives machetes
so would you call yourself an influencer
um well yeah so you could give me that
labor at the fair let me get this
straight let me make friends understand
so this guy got robbed and beaten before
learns his lesson I I hope maybe not
with social media
puts in a bunch of security measures
then invites Vice to pretty much stake
out the whole place to show where all
the weapons and items are and what kind
of security and lists will he has so a
guard dog we know machetes machete on
top of the South
smart these people really are addicted
to like attention it's Frank or
oblivious no you got to be addicted and
you don't get through all these security
measures do all this stuff and then not
realize how stupid you gotta sound or
maybe you do maybe you do but good Lord
and well yeah so you could give me that
labor I had a fairly big following I
started doing quite well for myself just
posting it that was just me documenting
my success and my achievements at the
time what sort of things were you
posting 2019 I was quite young watches
clothes holidays so I was into my fast
cars and that's the car that I had
bright blue as well I was very yes yes
so tell me what happened I was in bed
and I've heard like like tapping
housing for the dogs I've obviously
escaped the bed and they've gone
upstairs I went I went upstairs to them
unprepared they've got machetes to say
where's your watches where's your drugs
I'm an influencer I don't know I mean so
flowers that have been chasing around me
I'll stop stop stop they were chasing
you around your house stabbing yeah yeah
just like asking for like different
stuff but you should poke me like one of
them went into my little girls room the
other guy which I have a tiny bit of
respect for him because he went now I
get out the room and then uh he punched
me
oh these are something
what
one of the guys went into his daughter's
room and the other guy said nah get out
we don't do that come out
so they didn't mess with the dog they
could have poked her and got this [ __ ]
and watched face yeah they could have
definitely pressed that button yeah but
he said we don't do that
listen I'm not saying thieving is good
but I respect a man with a coat
gentlemen's yeah shall we yes yes
was it was it
a man must have a code yeah yeah yeah
yeah
um obviously I must have put my arm up
or something and he just slipped my arm
so that looks quite big did you not lose
a lot of blood from that yeah yeah it
was quite a bit in time I don't remember
much after that I found the knife and
that's how he got caught a lot of
reaction to these influencers getting
robbed online was that they almost
deserved it because they were flaunting
their wealth online it does put you more
at fiscal I believe it cause of course
it does but you know it doesn't give
anybody the right to do anything
is the right thing they don't have the
right to but it does put you at risk and
that's the reality so there's a couple
of man past couple of rappers that died
in the states it was that them dancing
themselves and then people coming at
them and stuff like that you know I mean
it's
crazy it is I wish I don't wish that
upon nobody no that's crazy but
and that's not just influencers
you guys got to be mindful when you
travel the amount of time I see tourists
in the wrong spots wearing the wrong
kind of jewelry
happens all the time all the time
wearing the wrong kind of outfits
wearing designer brains when they go
into poor countries especially like in
Latin America I've been seeing people do
that and I'm thinking in my head like oh
you just want to be an easy Mark or
maybe you don't know and somebody needs
to teach you something but if you guys
are watching be smart about your travels
if you got money keep it at home they
don't need to know
they don't need to know and anybody who
takes an interest in your life because
you got money are probably not people
you want to take an interest in your
life anyways the upside is just not
worth the downside
so I would just tell you if you're
watching just be smart about that that's
it
you wear a lot of jewelry though
where oh yeah you getting robbed you're
getting robbed one day with your rings
and everything
Rings yeah
yeah that's God telling you that you
decide that you like huh that made the
wrong decision